the movie starts in a church where a
woman is reading a book to some children
a little girl notices wind gushing
towards the woman and forming her
doppelganger her eyes roll back as the
original notices her and screams in fear
shinobu takamura is a struggling painter
who is working hard for an upcoming
multi-national painting competition one
afternoon after failing to come up with
a decent painting idea shinobu has an
emotional meltdown just then a man
knocks on her door and introduces
himself as masaru her new upstairs
neighbor masaru's kindness and his
personality are a fresh breath of air
for shinobu who is used to being locked
inside her apartment every day in a
short time they fall for each other and
start living together at masaro's place
one evening masaru claims that he saw
her in the market earlier she thinks it
is strange because she was home the
entire day but they dismissed the
conversation shortly the following day
shinobu goes to a convenience store to
buy groceries but the cashier accuses
her of using fake cash he even shows the
cctv footage of her buying groceries
yesterday using the bill with the same
serial number on it shinobu is in shock
because she knows she hasn't come to the
store in the past month and is
definitely carrying real cash however
her word is not enough to convince the
cashier soon a cop named kano arrives
and brings shinobu outside she still
tries to explain her case but before she
finishes the cop says that he believes
her he shows her both bills and one of
them turns into dust out of nowhere
shinobu is left speechless and confused
kano reveals that the situation is a lot
more complicated than she thinks it is
and he needs some time to explain it to
her later he brings her to a house where
a group has gathered to discuss the same
problem it turns out that the person
shinobu saw on the cctv footage is her
doppelganger also known as her by
location a bilocation is created when a
person feels an extreme emotion that
overwhelms them it is an exact copy of
the original person one that has the
same memories emotions and personality
the leader of the group is a man named
makoto he reveals that bilocations think
that they are real but are actually
created from a person's energy and will
disappear when the person dies the
information is too overwhelming for
shinobu so she refuses to believe it but
on her way out she comes face to face
with her by location she disappears in a
few seconds but the brief interaction is
enough for shinobu to believe everything
she was just told after that a girl from
the group named mayumi offers to drop
shinobu off at home on their way she
reveals that she is a chronically ill
son who has been in the hospital for his
entire life a few months ago she was
told by hospital staff that they saw her
in parts of the hospital where she
wasn't allowed this went on for a few
days before one afternoon her son
disappeared and was found in the park
the record said that she was the one who
took him outside which is when she found
out about the bilocation mayumi also
warns shinobu that the bylocation might
try to steal something that is precious
to her when they stop at a red light
mayumi's bilocation appears out of
nowhere and starts banging on the window
shinobu is shocked because the woman
looks identical to mayumi and she isn't
sure which one is real mayumi quickly
drives away asking her to be careful at
all times the next day officer kano
gives shinobu a mirror urging her to
check it time and again when she meets
new people this is the only way to
identify a doppelganger because their
reflection is not visible in the mirror
kano also tells her about how he got to
know about his by location a month ago
he was about to be promoted at work but
was facing problems because of his boss
when he and his boss already had
differences he was accused of
misbehaving at work he knows he never
talked back to anyone and soon found out
it was his bilocation who abused the
boss he was demoted because of the
incident and wants to kill his
bylocation to take revenge after the
meeting shinobu is walking home and kano
approaches her again when she checks the
mirror she doesn't see his reflection
and the realization washes over her face
she tries to run but he pulls her back
and proceeds to punch her the real kano
arrives shortly thereafter and stops him
but before he can kill the by-location
it disappears in the next meeting
shinobu is concerned about the attack
made on her yesterday this time a man
named kaga is also present in the
meeting he is the first member of the
group and the one who is conducting an
extensive study on bilocations shinobu
finds him mysterious but doesn't voice
her thoughts she is told that before
talking to any member of the group over
the phone she must say a code word that
consists of all of their names that's
one long ass code word that way they can
ensure she is not a doppelganger then
makoto further explains that kano's
bylocation was created because of his
anger towards his boss which is why he
is so aggressive similarly all by
locations have their own defining
personalities so they don't have to
worry too much about being attacked
again furthermore the bilocations can
only exist within a 1.5 kilometer radius
of the original and will disappear if
they try to walk further from that
distance they also get hurt when the
original gets hurt which is a good way
of separating them if they are ever in a
fight at night shinobu hears the news
about three people being killed outside
the police station and the culprit is
none other than kano shinobu immediately
figures out that it must be his
bilocation who killed the people she
calls makoto who asks her for the code
before inviting her to their
headquarters porcano is on the floor
clueless about what he can do to save
his reputation the group decides to kill
the bilocation at all costs now that it
is creating so much trouble in the
following scene they go to an abandoned
building to wait for the bylocation to
materialize near the real kano the plan
works and the doppelganger arrives at
midnight the real and fake kano get into
a fight making it hard to differentiate
between them they should have made kano
wear a silly hat one of the members of
the group is a university student named
takumi he manages to get his hands on a
gun but doesn't know whom to shoot on
makoto's order he shoots randomly and
kills the real kano with him the
doppelganger also dies and the plan
fails shinobu returns home and packs her
bags to stay away from her boyfriend for
a few days so the by-location would also
be away from him before leaving she
tells him that she loves him somewhere
else mayumi goes to her son and gives
him a hand mirror she asks him to always
check if he can see her reflection in
the mirror and if he doesn't he is
supposed to run away the kid agrees and
hugs his mother poor little bastard must
be terrified the next day takumi is in
one of his classes when his bylocation
attacks him he runs to another room and
calls makoto to save his life when asked
about the code takumi forgets to say
kaga's name even though he is the oldest
and the most prominent member of the
group still makoto doesn't doubt him and
agrees to help suddenly the bilocation
barges in through the window and attacks
him again amidst the fight the original
pushes the fake out the window when he
still hangs by the wall the original
cuts his hand which makes a cut in the
by-location's hand as well causing him
to fall and disappear then we see mayumi
with her son in his hospital room she
tries to walk him outside but he refuses
to come with her claiming that she is
not his mother mayumi is in shock but
the kid remains adamant because he used
the mirror technique as his mother had
asked him to a flashback shows us that
one night mayumi was tired of always
having to take care of her son she tried
to choke him to death but regretted the
decision right away this feeling of
regret and the will to protect her son
created her by location hence the
bylocation frequently takes the kid away
because she doesn't want the original to
hurt him later that day shinobu mayumi
and of the university student takumi
meet without makoto they think that the
leader is trying to scam them since he
did nothing to help takumi earlier when
he was attacked they also believe the
first member kaga is on makoto's side
planning something against them just as
they talk the doppelganger takumi
attacks the real one mayumi hits him
from behind and makes a cut on his back
to their utter surprise the injury also
transfers to the takumi who they thought
was their friend this means that the
person they were talking to earlier is
the bilocation and the attacker is the
original unable to comprehend what is
going on the women run away mayumi is
soon attacked by another mayumi who
stabs her to death again the injury
doesn't transfer to the killer which
means the person who shinobu thought was
her friend is also a by-location god
damn she runs away to her home and has a
hard time processing what is real and
what isn't at one point she questions
her own existence the only person who
has the answers is makoto she goes to
the headquarters and finds him and kaga
together makoto says that he wants to
protect her and the others but shinobu
doesn't believe him after everything
that has happened to answer all her
questions kaga takes shinobu to a mental
hospital the next day it is the place
where makoto met his wife sisha for the
first time they were married for 10
years before makoto found out she was
actually a bilocation the day he found
out was the day the real sisha committed
the unthinkable she had been locked in
an asylum for the past 25 years before
makoto could comprehend his wife's
existence she disappeared in front of
his eyes he always believed that by
locations deserve a life like the
originals which is why he created a club
for them the people shinobu was meeting
in the club were all by locations who
didn't realize their true identity
makoto is sad he couldn't protect them
but he has vowed to take care of shinobu
that day shinobu returns home and goes
to her apartment where she sees her by
location still shocked by her existence
she runs back to makoto again makoto
reveals that he has met all the
bilocations and their counterparts the
headquarters consists of two rooms the
first one with green curtains which is a
place for bilocation meetings and the
other one with red curtains which is a
place for their originals kago only
stays in the green room because he has
no bilocation that way makoto can tell
who is original and who is it by
location by seeing if they take kaga's
name in the code he does so to
differentiate between the two and save
them from each other his intentions have
never been bad but they have caused many
deaths a flashback shows us the day
shinobu first met her boyfriend she was
going through a crisis after struggling
to generate ideas for a painting this
overwhelmed her so much that the
by-location was formed at the same time
her now boyfriend knocked on the door
and the by-location met him this is when
we find out that the person we've been
following since the beginning of the
movie is the bylocation of shinobu she
has been living with her boyfriend in
his apartment while the original shinobu
lives in the upper apartment and hardly
comes out because of work shinobu
refuses to believe this because she can
see her reflection in the mirror but
makoto discloses that by locations can
see their own face in the mirror but
others can't this has caused frequent
confusion like the real kano meeting
shinobu in the restaurant when she was
attacked shinobu finally realizes that
she was able to see two reflections in
the mirror when she first saw the real
shinobu her knees grow weak upon finding
out the truth about her existence but
makoto promises that he will help her
live her life as she pleases shinobu
returns home that day and her boyfriend
proposes to her with a ring the proposal
is bittersweet for her now that she
knows how fragile her existence is later
the real shinobu gets a call from the
art gallery and discovers that her
painting has won the competition but
when she sees the said painting she
realizes it was drawn by her by location
the original's only wish in life was to
win this competition and she is furious
at the buy location for taking it away
from her in a final showdown they meet
in the headquarters where the bylocation
asks the original to take care of her
boyfriend she is ready to give up the
prize her career and her boyfriend for
his happiness the original reluctantly
agrees and walks away after that the
bylocation goes to meet her boyfriend
for the last time he is excited about
their wedding and wants her to look for
a suitable wedding gown as soon as
possible as they chat the original
shinobu commits the unthinkable in the
last scene the man looks down the
balcony and sees her dead body when he
turns around to look at his girlfriend
she has already disappeared subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching